that the way my mind
[Laughter]
he was whining didn't tell a single
thing he moved his waist oh he did he
had to he had no choice
[Music]
okay guys welcome back
to all of you who came to see us last
week at the live show thank you very
much it was a Vibe it was light it was
good it was juicy we had a ball and
cannot wait for the next one guys that's
just to start so just thank you for that
if you missed it Peak if you missed it
wouldn't want to be you your business
yeah if you missed it I
um because sometimes like you know when
they say lightning doesn't strike twice
facts you just had to be there unlucky
but there will be another one and
hopefully
light lightning yeah you get it at that
time yeah yeah anyway guys welcome back
guys you're chilling with your boys Jay
Money And Fire Lord for eggs and before
we go any further what we need you to do
is pause the episode right now and head
on over to patreon.com forward slash
shits and gigs it's gonna cost you a
humble three pound a month 10p a day you
need to run the P to SMG and I'm gonna
tell you why guys once you get over
there you're gonna find three years
worth of episodes that you can binge
through that no one else but the cult
baby Community has seen guys no one's
seen these episodes but the cult baby
community so if you identify as a cult
baby you need to head on over to patreon
guys it's literally cheaper than chips
if that's not good enough for you guys
you're also going to get a bonus episode
every single Thursday so if you want to
keep up with the lingo keep up with
what's happening keep up with the cult
updates and jump in the Discord server
newly promoted
burnished Discord server for all the cop
babies to chat there's I'm not gonna
like there's chirps over there there's
chirps and threads all breeding ground
there's literal breeding grounds some of
the stuff I've seen said in exchange
over there is heinous if you're down for
it three pound a month heading over to
patreon.com
if you are watching this on YouTube
please like the video if you liked the
video chirps a thing in the comments
notifications on subscribe to the
channel facts
and finally guys for the audio listeners
for the audio beautiful beautiful audio
listeners who listen on your commute
listen while you're cleaning the house
listen not work guys if you're listening
on Spotify Audible
flip in Amazon Amazon Google Apple
podcast guys we ask one thing of you
guys please leave a nice review five
stars is preferable but say it with
chest whatever you do do with chest
facts
and guys that's enough spill for today
I'm gonna pass you over to my comrade
it's been three years in the making Fire
Lord forges over here to shed some fun
facts for us all today and let's have
some last let's learn some [ __ ] and uh
over to flex in 1915 a woman arrived
late at her sister's funeral when she
arrived she demanded that the sister's
coffin be open so be raised so she can
see her one last time upon opening the
coffin her sister Essie Dunbar sat up
and smiled at her she went on to live
another 47 years
so was it practicing or they actually
thought she was dead they actually
thought she was dead but I'm not gonna
lie to you like
if I've attended this funeral yeah I'm
just I'm not probably not a relative but
I know them know them through someone
else yeah
I'm gonna be internally asking questions
when SC sisters demanding that coffin be
brought up why
demanding
she said I need to see my sister again I
don't care how late I was yeah
raise that raise it up raise it up oh
I'm making I'm looking around to see
I'll surely other people should be
reacting the way I'm reacting internally
because this is nuts you killed her all
I'm thinking is you buried her alive and
you regreted it
because why weren't you here early yeah
you're my sister my detective mine's
going mad where were you where was when
when everyone else arrived why are you
late because it sounds like to me
you drugged her buried her alive
regretted it
decided you won't come to the funeral
because obviously [ __ ] her [ __ ] yeah
facts and then regretted it second
conscience Captain conscious crept in
you felt bad you rushed over there and
demanded we bring up the the bring up
the coffin and open I need to see her
again demanded
and once we did it
she's alive and her sister just sat and
smiled and your sister said that's too
kawinky dinky that's far-fetched
someone handcuff her someone handcuffs
someone yeah because I can't
I can't let that leave this area like
that's that's that's not okay
this isn't a fun fact she's a murderer
this isn't a little Fun Factory she's
committed crimes and she deserves to be
panicked oh that's jokes who's asking
her the questions bro and why is she
sitting up and smiling she was being
buried alone she was being buried alive
and she sat up and smiled this whole
thing is convoluted bro it's it's so
many holes here it's sketchy it's just
clearly the detective skills back in
them days weren't what they are yeah
yeah they weren't top-notch no one had
intuition yeah people just fought raw
miracle
back then people just said God
lazy raw a miracle
bro they were just praising anything
that happened back then yeah yeah no one
they had no Skeptics yeah they had no
balls to question it yeah they [ __ ]
balls the question if you say the Lord
did it yeah no one's saying that nah nah
nah nah he did no one said he did this
that is a shady because you would get
burnt alive you questioned the Lord
right you're getting burnt blasphemy
what do you mean the Lord didn't bring
her back that's blasphemy and the Lord's
speaking through his sister to make sure
it happens facts if you if you disagree
it's blasphemy packs
[ __ ] you oh my days not happening
um but that's actually coincidentally
leads on to my show recommendation of
the day
okay
fam I already know you must have seen it
because everyone's seen it I haven't
finished it I'm gonna spoil it I hope
it's what I'm thinking of Dharma
I started yesterday I watched three
episodes back to back I watched three
episodes back to back to back Ace I'm
spoiling it's a show it's the best show
it's Ace what are you up to because it's
10 episode seven oh [ __ ] bro you ain't
seen nothing you ever seen anything [ __ ]
I've just finished episode three [ __ ]
all right hit me I'm gonna spoil it but
in my defense it's a true story I know I
know it's basically true yeah yeah it
will still have the same impact what
it's spoiling the whole thing I don't
care oh I feel I'm sorry but I don't
actually care I'm on episode three I
broke okay that's up to you that's on
you
I'm spoiling it
all right do all you need to do all
right
actually from what you've seen is
actually not a spoiler okay because it's
just more development for stuff that
you've already seen okay
so
um so actually there was one bit that I
would talk about that I'm not going to
talk about okay because you need to see
it okay there's a bit the way they've
shot this
they get you in the mindset of my man of
my man in the later episode okay they
get you in the mindset yeah what they
focus on like the way they focus on some
of these murders yeah because some of
them obviously that you've seen some of
them focus on okay let me get the
context because I'm going to stumble
through of course of course guys if you
haven't seen Dharma oh my God so it is
kind of like a biopic series
um of Jeffrey Dahmer uh who was a serial
killer in the 90s 80s and 90s 80s and
90s um in Milwaukee
um USA
oh my [ __ ] I got so this series 10 part
series just on Netflix goes through
It's Like An Origin story somewhere
we've got yeah when he was arrested
we've got like interviews and it's all
based fan I don't know if you've seen
this bit here they have real calls oh
yeah I've seen that was on at the end of
episode two I think yeah yeah yeah
calling um the officer making sure that
are you sure it wasn't a child fam are
you sure it wasn't a trial when I saw
that that was a real call I was like oh
my God that's what I'm going to talk to
you about this is okay so this is what
the what I'm going to talk to you about
her name is Beverly that's a neighbor
yeah yeah I can't remember oh or is it
no it's Glenda okay Glenda Cleveland
don't say Beverly Glenda Cleveland
there's an episode just about Glenda
Cleveland OH sick
yeah so for context guys Glenda
Cleveland in the real life uh Dharma
case was his next door neighbor lived in
the apartment next to him and had an air
vent connecting the two apartments so
she would smell [ __ ] she would hear [ __ ]
and she would complain complaining she
would complain she would confront him
and she'll come she didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on but she was here and
screaming she was here and chopping she
was hearing all sorts everything
everything so guys for more context on
Dharma what he used to do so he was a
homosexual guy and he would he he got
sexual gratification from murder
yeah and he didn't want to be left alone
yeah so yeah so big part of his mer like
his motivation for killing was his
fascination with he also he had a sexual
fascination with organs organs this and
but this what was it dismemberment
dismemberment disembowelment oh that's
not all that stuff yeah yeah
he loved the way like innards looked
um for one when he was wanking and he
dashed the magazines and it flashed to
the guts
in the fish tank yeah the fish guts the
stinky fish guts wow wow wow so for one
he got gratification or a Rouser he's
not even gravity he got arousal from the
the site of like body parts inside like
guts and [ __ ] for two
um
he just loved to hold dead people I
don't even know if he was banging these
man because he's always grips in him
he's always holding them
have you seen the mannequin bit yet yeah
that was episode two or three I think
yeah cool yeah oh yeah cool so he like
he just used like to hold people
um and basically obviously he was gay as
well so what he would do is just pick up
Perez bring him back to the yard Dragon
yeah
kill him and hold them I'll take
pictures pics pictures he had their mind
contorted contorted headless yeah
Timeless fam when when homeboy was going
through the picks and saw a man
if I was an officer and I'm scrolling
through just pics of gays
because I'm putting my head in the 90s
this is how they were treating it sure
that's all he's thinking true these are
just Polaroids of gays
because he kept saying don't go in there
there's just gay [ __ ] in there yeah and
the [ __ ] was was it was yeah they didn't
want to deal with unless I don't touch
anything there's Gage there's just gay
[ __ ] in there and the cop was like [ __ ]
yeah he went in as a shop I need to see
yeah saw the Polaroids fam saw one thing
of some black bear doing some backing
here and said raw so the next thing of
the exact same prayer with no head
and then skip to the next one and so and
you look back and said these are real
yeah these are real
Drew for his gun I would have been the
same I would have started saying fam the
way in the first episode the way the
black brother was dancing for his life
that's what I'm talking about before I
get to okay before I get to Glenda
Cleveland there is a scene in there guys
first episode one he gets a victim and
the guy knows he's a victim yeah yeah
yeah and he says I just want to take
some photos somebody said okay he knows
he's gonna die yeah get the camera the
way he was whining to save his life he
fan his waist didn't so this didn't tell
a single FIB that entire sequence of
that the way my man
[Laughter]
he was whining didn't tell a single
thing he moved his waist oh he did he
had to he had no choice
just there caveat
he had eyeballs on him
they were big they were Pokemon they
were big that was probably the fair that
was the fear James I don't think you get
it he was dancing for his life he
actually was hot also I'm not putting my
back to him I don't care how bad I want
to sensualize this yeah yeah he's not
seeing my back oh yeah right
and Jeffrey Dahmer was big he was his
forearms oh he worked out bro his
forearms
beanie yeah yeah he knew what he was
doing so when oh bro as soon as I saw
the the height difference the size
difference between this victim I was
like it's a wrap yeah he's actual prey
the Blackberry yeah yeah a man said to
him
he laid on his chest I want to hear your
heartbeat
family's listening to his heartbeat
oh I'm gonna eat that later something
like that yeah he said I want to hear
your heart because I'm gonna eat it
family Chris was beaten even faster
I promise you now a grown man could
never lay on my chest whilst we're
watching The Exorcist three three he
says he watches it every day every
single day lay an extra patch of blood
on his mattress next man's blood
and he's got a drill with blood coming
out of it there's all sorts I know I'm
getting murdered and he's laying on my
chest and I'm Gonna Eat Your Heart
when I was watching that I was literally
saying to myself
I think we've said this before when you
have the fight or flight yeah I'm
thinking
I genuinely don't know because the whole
time you're watching that scene you're
thinking fight here yeah yeah yeah yeah
do something elbows bro you need to do
science to get out of there yeah and
he's Frozen with it yeah and then I'm
watching I'm thinking looking at that
size difference I'm thinking I might be
Frozen with her as well because he's got
a knife there yeah so if I rock it it
wasn't any knife oh it was a machete
he had a
[ __ ] knife [ __ ] so I'm thinking if
I'm gonna rock this guy as hard as I can
if he doesn't go down I'm dead
but if I whine and dine him yeah he
might let me live
he might literally what
um
no music
no music
he was there food I don't think you
understand how much of how full I am
looking back I can't get my words out I
don't think you understand how much I'm
looking forward to watching this episode
back and why should I just do this on
camera
he was
there and then he crawled on the floor
and he was backwards there like this his
back was arched he said you want me
to take some pics a man said let's go to
the other room and he sucked his finger
he was he oh when I saw that I was like
oh he stood up and Drew for the knife
bam they [ __ ] play games suck me off
he drooper and I don't play games with
me stop playing with me stop playing
with me toy with me I said are you high
yet when he are you high yet
pot that would have been red flag number
one are you high yet
pardon sorry Amanda said yes yeah
because he knew he knew his fate he knew
his fate no bro I that's that was
episode one one I've never felt fear
like that watching anything through had
fear yeah it was I'm thinking I might
freeze up like him because this size
difference yeah it was it was it was mad
what am I gonna do it was mad
what am I gonna do it was mad
I'll beg him just write me or something
don't kill me
I would I could I couldn't beg him to
rape me in that moment well you're lying
in a patch of next man's blood
because whatever he's gonna do is worse
yeah whatever he's gonna do is work true
just don't kill me just bang me just
save me please kill me please oh
one of Dharma guys is literally the
scariest thing I can imagine chilling
bro scariest thing I can imagine now let
me get to the Glenda Cleveland episode I
think it's episode seven or eight okay
oh dear okay
so Glenda lived next to my man for the
whole time he lived there okay when he
was killing man's so bro check this out
this is real life this is real life bro
so she would wake up so bearing in mind
so the stuff that you've seen she would
smell it she was smelling pear [ __ ] yeah
all that [ __ ] yeah through the vent and
she would knock on his door and be like
bro the smell is mad my mom said I had
some meat that went off or whatever so
this dead fish dead fish all this stuff
so he was making up excuses so what
happened was
what happened was
um
oh my God
oh my God I couldn't I couldn't bear to
be like how she survived this I do not
know like I'm not even talking about
survived him survived it mentally okay
fuhad listen to me now when I say this
woman went through it went [ __ ] threw
it hit me
so
she would smell the shafts the stuff
[Music]
would um say stuff to Jeff
nothing would ever come of it she knows
something [ __ ] up going in there fam
she would wake up to him hammering
soaring at like two in the morning
and she'd be like what the [ __ ] is going
on fuhad
on multiple occasions
this woman
woke up to screams coming from this vent
screen a grown man screaming saying no
stop stop please stop and hear Jeff
saying shut the [ __ ] up shut up be quiet
and then the scream will stop fuhad she
rang the police bad times that's the
trailer yeah
I said there's a fact there's one time
she rang and she said
brother send someone now yeah send
someone now there's there's a fight in
there and someone's gonna die someone's
she said someone's getting murdered next
door someone's getting murdered next
door come now Humber said I'll send the
car she said you don't know where I am
yeah you always say you're gonna send a
card she's I've been calling you man for
months someone's getting murdered man
said can you go check and make sure
for sure she said pardon
I just told you someone's getting
murdered I'm not gonna [ __ ] chat yeah
send a car I said yeah it will send
someone she said big man I haven't even
told you and he said listen if you're
gonna keep calling us all the time how
are we ever supposed to take you
seriously
hung up the phone
the screaming stopped
then we had the thing with the little
boy
in that episode two whatever yeah yeah
episode two or three the 14 year old
she rang the police bad times about him
um obviously her daughter rang the
police and said there's a guy he's naked
he's drugged he's bleeding he's a kid
help him
Jeff said two two sweet gatings fam and
he was up in the yard again Jeff is a
master manipulator I've only seen three
episodes and he's gotten himself out of
three or four situations with ease ease
with ease ease when he was um when he
um
this um he chopped off his first body
and he wanted to take it to some dump
site and he got stopped by the police
she messing his leaves what's all the
trash bags leaves fam and as soon as the
police um the the police officer left he
just stood in the car and took a deep
breath and
his crack told me this day
he's so calm so calm through your head
so he's seen [ __ ] oh bro so calm and
then so Glenda's going through it still
smelling stuff still hearing stuff this
whole hearing screaming when I'm telling
you if you had multiple times has
happened with multiple different breads
a prayer moved into the apartment
building
a prayer moved into the apartment
building a Gabriel gay black bear
introduced herself to Glenda making
friends making friends she said
everyone's lovely there's a few man you
need to watch out for
he said cool thanks for letting me know
I'll see you around
she witnessed as he's walking out bumps
into Jeff Jeff chirpses him by the front
that the in the hallway door yeah where
she's watching it
takes him out she looks out the window
they walk off to a bar together listen
to them come back
she never sees him again goes downstairs
his mail is packing up she goes to the
like uh the building manager and says
big man where is he he's gone I saw him
talking to Jeff I ain't seen him since
you need to go up in his yard and
imagine I can't go up in his yard she's
like listen to me now yeah
I keep complaining to you about Jeff
he's doing weird [ __ ] there's [ __ ]
crazy smells coming from his yard I need
him out bro and it's not even me making
the complaints is this woman made the
compass This Woman's made the campaigns
I've made the place you ain't doing [ __ ]
get him out
the manager goes to his yard to get him
out
um
I haven't got up to the park but
obviously he didn't get evicted so
Jeff's still doing [ __ ] she's ringing
the police all the time about him she's
talking to the building manager trying
to get him evicted nothing's happening
Jess just doing what he wants food had
she can't take it this is going on for
time so when he finally gets arrested
she's like brother I'm telling you man
I've been telling you yeah for months
yeah and you never come he's been
killing everyone
one spoiler I have to tell you
have to tell you imagine this as a
father okay so obviously when Jeff gets
arrested yeah
and he confesses to all these murders
they have to go around to all the people
who the victims are and tell their
families
now you remember the 14 year old yes he
said you took my brother yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so in a future
episode you will actually see that
happen Okay when he meets the brother
the brother at the time was 13.
13. so what happened was check this out
for racism
check this out for racism fuhad
the The Boy comes home he's been drugged
he escaped from Jeff he's been drugged
etc etc etc
they take Jeff to court
and say he's a child molester
take him to court so we want him in pen
the dad barely speaks any English
but he thinks she's all right the judge
is like when the dad is talking he's
like basila Prada I can't understand you
shut up
get one of your sons to speak for you I
can't understand you so then he starts
speaking his own language his son who
speaks perfect English translates it the
judge is like this is just noise
he said you've written it down in the
letter give your letter to bailiff this
is just this is this is a lot then Jeff
comes to Jeff and says for the crime
that you've and Jeff didn't even plead
not guilty
he doesn't say nothing so he's like you
haven't even denied the accusations this
is the maximum sentence but you don't
seem like the kind of guy that should be
in jail
so here's what we're going to do you've
got a full-time job you're going to go
pen for a year
every day from nine to five you can go
to your job and then you just come back
to pen
the family the family is like are you
joking
are you joking he's a child molester he
needs to go to Penn
wow and the judge was like nah it's calm
so he does his nickel bit of time comes
out then takes the brother
then the brother dies they have to go to
his yacht
and say your son has been murdered by a
guy called Jeffrey Dahmer
the dad loses his mind yeah
he said who
Jeff Dharma you mean the brother that
molested my son the son's there are you
talking about the same guy he's gonna go
mad bro he goes mad for the at the
police like you man imagine being that
father no bro I would I would be in jail
the next morning oh I'm murdering
everyone I'd be in Jordan I'm murdering
I have to find that judge oh I would
have to find that job so what would this
come with this all happening so now
we've got
thousands of calls from Glenda calling
the police no one ever comes yeah we've
now got a family who had one kid
molested by this guy and another kid
killed by this guy and all of these and
he's at this point in his like murdering
career he's sticking to blacks hmm
blacks and Asians he's just murdering
minorities so alongside his cases where
I'm up to now alongside his case for
actually just murdering people we've got
a huge civil rights case against the
police
um
at the same time okay being like how is
this humanly possible yeah yeah that
these people are literally crying for
help yeah from the same breath over and
over and over and over again there's
another breath that you'll see not much
of a spoiler there's another guy that
escapes from Death go straight to the
police goes and says this guy did X Y
and Z to me go to his yard I can take
you to his yard arrest him etc etc they
go to his yard they've got no evidence
and he's like the police I was like
there's nothing we can do and they said
all he's got his record is a few arrests
so what the [ __ ] are they arrest for
until I can't tell you
what the [ __ ] are the arrests for I said
I can't arrest he's had a few arrests
but can't tell you what they're about he
said is there anything pertaining to
what I'm talking about facts
I said I can't share that information
but he goes to the black guy you should
of all people should know
sometimes people get arrested when they
didn't do anything
the black guy says big man I've never
been arrested in my life I don't know
what you're talking about I've never
been arrested in my life he's like yeah
but you know what I'm talking about so
he said you're telling me you would
rather
take the word of a white guy that's been
arrested multiple times over a black guy
that's never been arrested in his life
just because of this social construct we
live in wow that's why Jeffrey was doing
what he wanted fuhad
that's why he was getting that's why he
was literally getting away with murder
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
people wow
wow I'm very much looking forward to
throw the rest of when I say when you
get in the mindset there's one episode I
won't support anything all I'm gonna say
is a victim's called Tony
when you meet Tony okay
lock in
lock in
episode say less episode say less your
heart and your brain won't know which is
which yeah Jeffrey goes through it okay
Jeffrey goes through it okay
okay wild say less that show is I can't
wait to finish it yeah yeah something
else I can't wait to finish actually
sign us it's some of the best [ __ ]
they've put on Netflix in a minute oh
one million is haunting yeah yeah good
is [ __ ] horny pretty [ __ ] good we
now watch that Glenda episode I was like
I don't know how she made it through
this
she's hearing man getting murdered next
door and calling police and no one's
coming
[ __ ] wherever I'm trying to figure out
where
I'm trying to figure out what I've seen
his brother from yeah the main guy Jeff
oh he's in a few things
so he's in X-Men as quicksilver
okay um he's also in
um
what else have I seen him in
he's also in
I can't remember I remember he's
definitely an X-Men
I can't remember what else he's in let
me um pull up his name Evan Peters yeah
he's a good actor
so yeah quick silver like you said
I think I've probably seen him more in a
couple of series as well
oh he's in Deadpool as well oh yeah
Quicksilver
um series okay Ah that's it American
Horror Story I knew it was amazed before
yeah I swear he's a main bread in
American Horror Story yeah yeah yeah
yeah Fair [ __ ] play fair play to him
fair [ __ ] place he's an actor yeah
yeah cause I know I've seen it his face
is familiar no he's doing the most yeah
yeah yeah Dharma boy he's doing the [ __ ]
he's a most in there okay guys time to
pay some bills we're gonna take a little
minute of your time to bring awareness
and love to the boys and girls over at
manscape guys right
welcome to fresh Bowl fall guys fresh
ball full come on don't go wrong with
that can't go wrong with a fresh Ball
Four it's the season of pumpkin spice
and making sure your crotch looks nice
let's go come on let's go the
alliteration is moving mad
um that means sip inside out in a full
Breeze and using manscape products to
trim your balls with ease what's this
Jolly Jolly what's this Jolly Jolly
rhyme rhyme fam
[Music]
that's right guys Today's Show is
brought to you by manscape a company
here to make sure that your foliage
isn't the only thing shedding in excess
leaves
even Mother Nature knows it's time to
hang on
even
right even Mother Nature knows it's time
to lose the excess clutter for fall join
the six million men now guys you heard
it say two million you had to say four
join the six six million men worldwide
who trust Mass gate by going to
manscape.com
code
sng Sierra November gold for 20 off and
free shipping worldwide guys go let's
get back to the episode yeah [ __ ] oh
that show's crazy it's really good yeah
bro that first [ __ ] episode had me on
the ropes yeah the the dancing thing
that wine for his life was like oh my
God the wine for his life I I can't
I pray to God I don't ever experience
fear like that fam that was fair I pray
to God he had nothing else but that
dance and on top of that
um what's mad is that this is actually
this is what's [ __ ] up when I was
thinking about the
the difference in size okay and he's
thinking I can fight my way out
probably lose and definitely die
or I can just do what he tells me and he
might let me live yeah probably won't
yeah but my name is what a woman goes
through all the time
[ __ ] facts bro when a woman gets
attacked to rape and assaulted that must
go for a head all the time I could
either fight this brother
definitely lose
and still take this l
or I can just sit here and firm it and
maybe he'll let me live
[ __ ] bro
dark dark let's just not go home with
prayers facts how about that facts let's
just stop going home with breasts
because that's scary that's dark bro
that's scary it's very dark who had that
scary of course it is
that realization I was like Wow nothing
I've never never yeah I ain't got that
problem because no chicks having me up
like that
it's true it's facts yeah no one's
having me up like that yeah yeah but if
I'm gay or female oh dear
um
oh dear it's long
literally long
because watching that I was like
Jesus Christ that's terrifying because
there's nothing I'm watching I'm
thinking look at that size different I
think there's nothing he can do there's
nothing he could have done literally
nothing you can see he's lucky
he was lucky how he got that out that
door is beyond me because I'm I was
thinking
obviously in the the beginning of the
first episode they show him like trying
to get out the door like the Jeff and he
bangs the door so you have to do in a
specifically yeah Mr Jimmy yeah I'm
thinking this black red is not going
anywhere
you don't know how to Jimmy the door
he's not getting out but man as soon as
it went a jar of a little while thinking
yes yes he got out Escape but I was
thinking is he still gonna grab him by
his uncle and drag him back in he was
gonna drag him back in he was running
when you go outside
he was rocking running so would I oh
I would run on top of the police car and
held the roof
I would have held the roof but bro the
and again the internal conflict of my
man run into the police car with that
handcuff on him and they're telling him
to put his hands up and going he's lucky
they didn't shoot him bro he's lucky
they didn't shoot that's what I'm
thinking imagine they did it Matt
because I was expecting them to shoot
him oh can you imagine like are you
actually I expected them to kill him and
I was thinking [ __ ] he's never gonna get
caught yeah yeah yeah yeah literally
[ __ ] that would have been a chilling
first episode wait it still was but if
he got killed I was thinking oh [ __ ]
this is going to develop hello I'm
telling you now as soon as as soon as I
walk in that apartment and I smell that
stank I'm leaving oh fact sir everyone's
like what's that smell as soon as I walk
into a weird guy's apartment and it
smells like Rotting Flesh gone bye he
locked the door with haste
lock padlock [ __ ] what's the the
thingy lock little chain the little
chain thing another lock another lock I
promise you now I couldn't watch a great
man do that I couldn't go into a
gourmet's house looking at his tropical
fish hear the door closed hear one knock
turn around and seem to change a lot and
then flick
[ __ ] all of that I'm looking for weapons
fam when man sat him down on a bed with
a knife shaking the thing is I don't
think that I can't remember the black
guy's name but I don't think he used
obviously it's a fight or flight he was
obviously
um struck with fear but the time Dharma
turned back to sort out the TV and the
knife was the head that's when I would
attack him
that's what I'm talking about when I say
literally internal copy because it's
like you've got one chance you I don't
think you'd have the confidence to be
like this is when I'm taking him out
because you'd need him to be occupied
for like five or six more seconds
yeah there's no way you could be of
sound mind or body that as soon as he
turns his back they'd be like yeah
you'll be shaking because I want nothing
and you'll be like this is my job and
then but by the time you've processed it
he's turned out loud yeah when he told
him to get the camera and man said
and he went he went to get a thing and
he came back quick yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he needed to
commit he needed to commit that's why he
started on this floor thing it's like
yeah he started doing that floor one
you want to see me get naked you want to
see me take my pants off right let's go
to the other room let's go to get to the
camera Jeffrey can help himself he knows
he's killing him he still had to get the
car yeah yeah
yeah Jeffrey had also had internal
conflict oh he did he loves man he loves
man he loves killing he loves a man he
loves organs yeah he literally does he
has no what's mad he's gay as [ __ ] he
has no interesting [ __ ]
mad no interest in it he wants to smell
you and hold you yeah yeah he just wants
P it's mad because obviously as this
show goes on you see a lot of his
backstory again I'm only on episode four
but you see a lot of the fact that he
was one he was an only child no he had a
brother brother he had a brother which
got taken away from him drapes because
they um his parents split up and he was
only really really close to his dad but
he's his dad knew was a weirdo but he
said you always said to him you're a
good kid you're a good kid you're a good
kid and he just wanted to be loved he
just wanted someone always with him and
that's the reason why he just kept on
nabbing people and holding him hostage
tell you one more time Tony say less
that episode's gonna rock your world
saying less I promise you now it's gonna
rock well I'll finish it this week good
Lord I'll finish it this week good luck
that's [ __ ] say less fam when they
nabbed him they're asking silly Billy
little questions uh like why did you
kill all these fam if I've got 37 bodies
yeah don't ask me questions about why
why it's a pattern it's a happy I do
this on a date it's a potion yeah I'm a
serial killer that's wow
if I kill one person ask me why maybe
two ask me why if I've got bodies bodies
body bodies over years don't ask me
silly little questions about why just
lock me up I've already confessed just
lock me up yeah yeah yeah oh I found
when they bought the dad in he didn't
know what was what and the first when
they told him everything he had done and
he said at the end
we we might not be sure but from the
traces of the the blades and the the
carcasses it seems as if he eats them
too
I couldn't hear that by my son I said
you've got the wrong person this is a
cell there's no way my son you're
telling me not only murders people not
only keep souvenirs in the fridge
eats them eats them too
in one episode you see the first time
you eat something
um
oh I I saw it what was it did not eat
the the fish stuff no no no I'm saying a
human oh I've seen it eat um you eat the
fish stuff yeah I'm talking human being
oh God Cooks up a human steak oh God
family Cooks it up and he's he's nervous
but excited
and he just like
sees it
eats it and as soon as it was he's like
oh god oh it's it's it's terrifying I
wonder what that would do to a man oh I
could I couldn't
you can't fathom him eating human flesh
I'm not doing that I promise you now I'm
not doing that I'm not doing that you
will in the right circumstance
I'd I don't think I would to be fair I
ain't felt hunger like that
I ain't felt hunger like that you would
in the right circumstance Jesus Christ
if there was me you and a random third
party on a desert island
and we just managed to create a fire
he has to go how hungry are we what a
deserted islands
has it been it's already it's already
been a week we've been on an island for
a week now and we've we've we've found
all the Coconuts that I need finding I
hate coconut yeah but I'm back at them
anyway I'm drinking all the water I'm
back in all the fruit
none of us can fish yeah to save our
lives and we all hate fish it is long
it's long we're not catching them
slippery [ __ ] yeah yeah you a modest
by accident I just grew up I vomited but
I can't do this anymore I need flesh
I need flesh and then I turn to my man
he's just jogging he's bearing he's
bearing he doesn't understand the inside
jokes he's up himself he's just
exercising for no reason he's not
resourceful he drinks bare coconut milk
he's a liability he's just about yeah
he's just a third wheel yeah yeah yeah
he has to go yeah yeah and his jokes are
terrible they just tell he has to go
yeah yeah he has to go not a week though
like what did Jesus do 40 days and 40
nights come on man we've got a week and
we're eating human flesh nah bro come on
we have to do better if I'm on a desired
island with no shelter I think I'll lose
it after two days
I would [ __ ] lose it after two days
James there's no way we can make it back
to civilization and have to come clean
with our sins and they say how long were
you there before you ate yeah you're a
boy seven days you can never turn to me
and say I don't think you might
understand
I had no food and shelter for two days
never here 48 Hours he was carving up
bodies
[Laughter]
it's been two days and I just lost the
plot I hated coconut I hate coconut and
I'm allergic to shellfish I had no
choice
[ __ ] I couldn't see the side of you two
days I'd be shaking you throughout stop
it's been two days my bro I can't take
it I'm hungry
laughs I'll look at you with I'll keep
you you're a little lost in your eyes
I'll be scramming if I look back at you
do you think bear take two steps back
because you could be next I promise you
now I'll be on high alert you couldn't
look her back at me anyhow because I'll
kick your jaw off
you couldn't be foraging and look back
at me anyhow because all you'll hear is
footsteps and a kick to the draw and
I'll be warning one
not be warning one
keep your predatory eyes away from me
off of mine
hungry gays averted we're boys yeah yeah
we're boys don't find them
I'll make threats oh my God I don't care
how hungry you are you're gonna have
trouble on your hands you're not eating
me you're not eating me you won't have
teeth to eat with
oh oh God man said A week a week bro the
week I'm gone I'm gone fam no shelter no
food a week you man don't think I don't
think you know about how long are we
human flash red the smell alone oh yeah
of course bro I would have to I think
bro after day four I'm already tapped
I'm drinking salt water for God's sake
I'm tapped already
I'm seeing [ __ ]
so it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
I've been seeing [ __ ] since Wednesday
oh my God
it just doesn't matter oh God that's
[ __ ] hilarious
Jesus for that I have no idea how funny
that is
it's Wednesday bro what's a little flesh
you know I mean what's a little bit of
fat oh [ __ ] I haven't laughed like that
in my life oh Jesus funny bro Bros call
me oh Jesus I'm hungry now as well oh so
funny what's a little fled
I've been seeing [ __ ] since Wednesday
[Laughter]
the thing is I know you'd I know
I'm picturing it now I know you
[ __ ] I know you're fat yeah you'd be
eating the thing off the bone and stay I
would stare at you one time and you'll
kiss your teeth and say don't [ __ ]
look at me
I'll be munching away and I'll look back
you're [ __ ] looking what else was I
supposed to do I'm hungry
I'm [ __ ] starving James shut up
you'll be there just shake grab a bone
and shark he was shaking oh you would
have internal conflict oh Rags because
you're like should I munch my man
because I'm starving now is getting me
that Smoky flavor's getting oh my God
and you're back in it off the boat a
whole thigh I'm grabbing the tibula and
the fibula brother
and damn it I'll be starving I'd be
starving and then I'll be live if I eat
it I'll be living at you I'll be so
angry at you
[ __ ] you we wouldn't speak for the rest
of the trip the trip
trip
I'd be so angry and obviously because we
can't finish a human in one day no
definitely we've got to save how where
we've got to wrap him in bananas and
bury him to keep the bugs away and then
when we dig it up um every single time
yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell that's jokes that is
too funny boy that is jokes
okay you got a trash news right yes I do
have a trash and he's [ __ ] now chess
player hands Neiman denies using sex
toys to help him beat a grand champion
have you heard this
oh of course yeah I've heard that when
you threw me with the sex toys but yeah
I've I've heard about this so
this is a brat who has been accused of
cheating so basically he had a match
with the like reigning world champ right
yeah Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlson and
within a couple minutes magazine Magnus
retired and said [ __ ] this so he walked
off oh no no no no no no this is a
different match he got he beat him
basically yeah Hans beat him
Magnus walked off didn't say nothing
um and then hasn't like didn't openly
say anything for days and then I think
he tweeted and basically was like I'm
keeping my mouth shut because if I say
anything it's it's beef so everyone
assumed they took that from cheating so
there's like little
um
yeah I wondering what what you can do to
cheat and one of the things is is
basically
like almost like a morse code kind of
thing so it would be like oh so someone
could easily like have a laptop be
watching the live like you could be at
home watching the match live stream and
then you can connect like little
electrodes or some people say you could
have like sex toys so you could have
like a little vibrating thing up your
body and then someone could be like C4
like Rook to C4 or whatever and just be
like one two three three vibrates for c
one two three four vibrates for for four
yeah
um so people are saying like he could
have something in shoe you get something
up his ass and there's loads of little
little nooks and crannies but the reason
they think he's been cheated because I
was like because my brother was balls
deep in chest that's how I know about
this oh okay okay balls deep okay my
brother loves chess okay so I'm playing
chessing years oh bro I'm terrible at
chess
um I played the computer I was I played
the computer I bought them on the plane
I lost in three moves the thing is I saw
it I was thinking I saw it once I just
looked away I was like I ain't
entertained I was born I'm
yeah next thing I know his Knight's
doing best yeah and he just said check
me
I close it up immediately close it up
and close my laptops
jokes um so so anyway
um basically I asked my brother how can
you even cheat in chess I can move as a
move as a move like what what do you
mean cheating and basically remember the
way my brother explained it to me
is that
the a computer doesn't understand the
difference so when a computer a computer
makes moves for you it will make
um there's certain things that
um
there's certain like ambiguous rules in
chess that such and such is a tie and
such and such is a like you're winning
or you're moving towards a tie but
there's certain moves
or intuition that a human has that a
computer doesn't have so for example we
could be playing
and there's it's hard really hard
because I don't really understand chess
but something to do with the fact that
like
I could make a move
that's like in chess terms is a tie but
a computer can't differentiate between
that and no we're winning okay so so
you're making moves that only a compute
would make because it does as far as a
human can it just doesn't make sense for
a human to make that move okay there's
certain there's certain things like that
oh okay there's certain things that and
I've seen on Tick Tock they had a
rematch I think okay they had a rematch
online
and literally one or two Moves In
the saint Magnus guy locked off The Ting
oh really literally two moves in Magnus
bang went offline and then I I looked on
Tick Tock because everyone was like
what's going on what's going on and then
someone on Tick Tock was like like
literally said something like Rook to E4
in this thing
no one in their right mind would make
that move only a computer would make
that move so there's certain moves that
our computer would make that don't make
logical sense for a human to make so
that's how they've like accused him of
cheating but so far I don't think he's
ever been like
convicted yeah I don't think yeah
there's been enough evidence to say that
he's definitely cheating but um let me
actually just read the yes you've given
basically what the context is yeah yeah
yeah I'm gonna read what it says a
teenage chess Grandmaster has been
forced to deny using a sex toy to help
claims to help him claim his crown in
one of the biggest scandals to hit the
game in years handing him and 19 an
up-and-coming star in the game was
sensationally accused online of using
anal beads connected to a computer
program that would vibrate and give him
the perfect AI move to defeat the number
one Grandmaster Magnus Carlson him back
at the internet room is accusing him of
cheating accusing him of using the anal
beads to cheat Neiman said if they would
Strip Me fully naked I will do it I
don't care because I know I'm clean
you want me to play in the closed box
with zero electronic Transmissions I
don't care I'm here to win and that is
my goal regardless
it came on it came as Elon musley in a
tweet um of an influenza discussing the
rumor that Neiman used the illicit
remote sex toy during the chess um
during the chess match and it just yeah
basically goes on to um what you
described yeah that's that's insane bro
I've read The Heading I was again this
doesn't make sense yeah bro it was it's
wild and I think also what other people
I think also happened I think he was
interviewed after the match okay
and said oh why did you do this and his
justifications for doing it
didn't make sense yeah well Bears us so
he might be like oh I did this because
if I do this it means that he can't do
this and that and then someone like
that's not true because if you do that
then it just means he does this and this
and then he'll be like uh yeah so like
his explanations for the moves you were
making just weren't making sense I mean
if I'm playing a game regardless of the
game I'm playing if if I'm making a move
and you ask me why did I make it because
I wanted to make the move not in chess
not in chess because chess is like chess
the only way you the chess the only way
you can be good at chess is if you can
spot the opponent yeah three four you
have to make moves to influence other
people to make moves so that you can
make moves like chess is not about I'll
move this so you can move this you can
move this you have to literally think
three four five steps ahead so if you're
moving any piece you should know
he's going to do this which means I do
this which means he does this which
means I do this that's how chess works
like you can't just do move by move so
there is anyone especially at his level
should never be asked a question why did
you do this and him be like because I
did like he has to explain calculate
okay otherwise you're a cheat wow
because you're playing the number one
guy in the world yeah yeah so even even
there would be situations where like
whether it be there could be like tennis
or something like that and like oh I
noticed that you did this shot in this
moment that's like unusual like why did
you do that like Roger Federer would be
able to like oh yeah I did that because
I've watched tape of him and he always
takes a double three step when he does
this so like I knew he was going to be
at the back of the court so I could just
give him a little thing like someone at
that level will know no yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no one's like I just
did it's on yeah if Roger Federer did
like a random like slice when he should
have done a Top Spin and someone said
why did you do the slice there's no way
he's been like I just did I just wanted
it I just wanted to was it Federal
retired yeah
I was Ballin and his hairline
his hairline retired long ago [ __ ] he's
got the thinnest hair I've seen yeah he
has he has he's got the he looked like a
horror like a horror character yeah it's
not his hair is
put out on
her hat on or reach you're Rich As [ __ ]
Yeah turkey and get him get him filled
in yeah
horrific I've never seen anything like
it it looked like straw yeah it was thin
very thin thin thinner yeah same thing
he looked old as well they might have
been playing yeah they might have been
playing for years
I like Roder Federer because like he's
always cool as well like you never get a
rise out of him for nothing never get a
rise up nothing yeah yeah and he's done
the damn he's done everything he's done
it all
Roger feder was a guy yeah Mom Roger is
a true gentleman yeah Mom
anyway
um what we got next oh I've got a mighty
[ __ ] now oh okay okay so
this is sent in by a female so my friend
has been talking to this guy for a while
and I'm oh I remember this I remember
okay cool I remember this one's juicy
okay this one's juicy all right buckle
up
so my friend has been talking to this
guy for a while and I'm happy she's
found that person she likes after a long
time she claims she wants to loyalty
test this guy and basically begs me if I
can flirt and see how far he's willing
to go
so I agreed however I originally didn't
want to as I have a really high sex
drive and because we are friends I know
he does too
so we ended up having sex
and it was phenomenal we've been doing
our thing for a while wow me and my
friend are complete opposites she's a
very calm romantic with hardly any
experience whilst I'm a freak
whilst I'm a freak with way more
experience am I the [ __ ] for letting
it go so far as it as I um
I might as ask for am I the [ __ ] for
letting it go as far as it did despite
the fact that my friend said I should
and knew what could happen if we did put
things on the table with him
this is the most outrageous request
we've ever received yes you are still
the [ __ ]
she said can you please loyalties test
him give him a bit of a chin wag and see
how far he's willing to go and you bang
you said bear turns out he's willing to
go all the way and you're a freak freak
and I know what he wants and where we've
been [ __ ] with the life for weeks
[ __ ] because you're a little timid
thing you're a timid thing and he
doesn't want that he wants me am I the
[ __ ] you put me in this position
knowing what could happen you know what
my drive is like
you know I'm about you know what I'm
about you put me on a deserted island
and there's flesh around what's in a
month I'm gonna cook it up would you
expect
if you're my friend you would have known
that about you would have known that you
wouldn't have asked me to help you and
it's not my problem
it's not my fault and it's not my
problem [ __ ] she's still the [ __ ]
though you're obvious yeah
you've [ __ ] your best friend's mine
regardless of even if your best friend
gave you the [ __ ] man on the plate
you should have done it bro if you turn
to me and we're like big man
can you loyally test my girl flirt with
her and see how far she's willing to go
if I know that about myself yeah and I
shouldn't be trusted how about big man
the answer's no because your girl's Peg
and if she's actually down I promise you
I'm banging her I promise you I'm
banging that I won't be to help myself
so no because I don't want to do that to
you or her the thing is I wouldn't even
want to know that truth
oh fam
obviously it's this is bance right now
but the when you just said
your wife is banging so if I get the
chance I'm going to bang her yeah we're
not boys is what you're doing that's
exactly what you're telling me I can't
do it because we're not but actually
boys and I fancy your girl more than I
love our friendship that's exactly what
you're telling me don't give it to me on
a plate don't give me that option I'm
yanking it from your hand
because I've looked her for time yeah
fam and I want that I want that and I'm
a freak and you're not I'm gonna have it
I'm gonna sample it I had a nurse and I
refuse to take the blame madness don't
put me in this position because I'm a
cleanup yeah because you know what my
sex drive is like it's a compulsion [ __ ]
bastard I'd expect you to be like well
obviously not boys so what are we even
talk what are we even talking about yeah
literally and also don't ever loyally
test anyone ever no stupid no just like
your loyalty exactly lock it off there's
no loyalty just lock it off yeah bro
that's no need for that [ __ ] stupid
it's not unnecessary unnecessary but it
was it was short and sweet but it was a
juicy one let's do it questions right
guys so we're going straight to ig
question and the question of the week
was we've actually done this prior so I
wanted to ask um our fans James asked um
no someone sent it to you someone said
to you I was the king that your partner
has that you went along with because you
loved it yes so James did a thread of
that from someone else and said it to
him so I thought I'd ask the questions
to the fandom and see what we got so
what's it called so again what's the
king that your partner has that you went
along with because you love them
she likes my initials being carved into
her
imma just keep rolling fam please roll
on from that what my ex used to let me
watch porn while she gave me head I was
scrolling through her sister's insta
no
no
liberties
Liberties I'm telling you certain
mentors don't care give him an inch yeah
I'm taking everything nine yards I'm
taking everything
he likes me fingering his [ __ ] and
used to [ __ ] his leg up instead of
asking for it
just like a dog let's put it up on the
table just eye contact and leg up gone
then gone then you know what I want you
don't make me ask come on
[Music]
huh
metal cable ties The Lads thought I was
cutting my wrists
Metals a bit much I didn't even know
they did metal cables neither did I
neither did I
Jesus she's extremely interested in
licking my hair and sucking on my locks
that's a possession that's a possession
that's a damaging what do you mean
you're sucking on my locks
you just like black skin yeah and not
attributes yeah and I don't know why
yeah get my locks out your mouth this is
scary this is disgusting it's a scary
story even feel anything I can't even
feel anything you're just munching on
hair but yeah are you all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] that he
wanted me to toss him off with my feet
and I tried it but I'm not too hold on
I'll get a phone call out of state I was
distracting the life out of me he wanted
me to toss him off with my feet and I
tried it but I'm not coordinated enough
to do that oh fair enough I don't think
many people are especially if the Tool's
not heavy
oh that might be all right
just a little like a bicycle ticket yeah
yeah hey you never know
my ex used to like my yeah my ex used to
like his balls being dipped in hot tea
and the let it drip on my chest
so like this is the thing with me right
with the King stuff like we can trace
back Jeffrey Dahmer's like Kinks from
child childhood yeah we're getting a
full picture yeah we understand why he's
the way yeah but yeah and even at the
end result he's not super specific he's
not like it makes sense
on a gate waiting that he likes seeing
like dead animals he likes dead animals
like guts and stuff he likes how shiny
it is it it's not crazy to assume that
eventually he's gonna like human ones
and then once he he's so obsessed and he
sexualizes the organ so much he wants to
eat it in fact that makes sense where do
we get to tea bag in actual body and
just letting it drop drip on you where's
the origin still yeah yeah how did we
get here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because
YT yeah bro why t y t I'm assuming he
just loves like yeah yeah Ting I don't
know but I don't know how we got here
and let it just drip on my chest it's
boring for everyone for everyone
involved and he's just solid
he's solid
he watching it dropping his solid solid
pulsing let's just play along nah I
promise there are certain things I can't
play along with yeah same my face would
express it all yeah especially after the
first time we're doing it once and we're
not doing it again because I'm not that
that's long there's no way homeboy could
turn and be like can we do the tea thing
again
all right back to it what's the king
that your partner has that you went
along with because you love them
this one put I didn't even love him but
he always wants to nut in between my
toes
oh dear
I didn't even love it
last joke my ex wanted me to bite his
nipples he'd be like harder oh dear I
swear harder
that's joke my sighting wanted me to
come over after my boyfriend knighted in
me seaming down my sighting
so he he specifically wanted that
wow
wow he wanted me to suck his tits like
he was the [ __ ] oh dear she liked to
sleep with my finger in her ass
that's interesting it is to an ex I mean
it's long it's
fingering in the ass is interesting as a
whole but to sleep yeah fam that's that
would
she would be livid because as soon like
that's triggering for me because as soon
as she's out I'll stick your finger up
there I'm horny yeah yeah exactly I'm
horny and then I'm gonna Bang Yeah she's
thinking I'm trying to sleep I'm trying
man so she might like she'll it's long
for everyone because she'll tell me to
do it then I'm horny obviously I've got
a bang yeah so we're banging and then
after
for what that's dead I'm just leaving it
in there how I can't your mum yeah your
mum I'm doing it once I'm banging you
and I'm going to see myself knotted on
my face and left it overnight
wow no
that's long because he's already had the
PNC so he just wants it's just a power
thing it is a power thing yeah
once he's bust that final nut yeah he's
got he's clear now he's in c-string yeah
and all this isn't enough yeah you need
to clean up and the fact that he wants
her to stay like that yeah no that's not
fair yeah you're playing with her mental
state yeah because it's not even a kink
because you're you're done you're done
you're out of that sex realm yeah you
just you're just a Power Trip Power Play
She said he liked to play classical
music during the deed
classical classical that's interesting
classical wow
X fling wanted me to call him a dog
whilst he licked my face and sucked on
my nose
interesting I had to dress up as
multiple anime characters even the
female ones
oh he's a breath yeah wow
dressed up as nezuko imagine with a
little The Crossings
nah jokes it's the last one my ex liked
Court cages and being told his dick was
small and couldn't satisfy me oh I bear
man love that
that's an interesting one because
the only way when I think about that I
was like the only way I'd like that is
if it's a prove you wrong thing you know
what I mean what do you mean so like if
someone's like
your tool can't do [ __ ] to me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah say swear
that's golden yeah yeah they're like
tell me again
it's disgusting isn't it tell me it
repulses you
and they're just all right
I can't sit there and be spoken to you
like that I can't be below yeah I just
can't be belittled by that in a sexual
manner as well yeah yeah if I had to
look at my thing about what's that
what's that doing to anyone oh hey bro
why are you doing this relax doing this
I'm a human yeah I have feelings too
literally I feel it stop stop [ __ ]
feeling stop stop but yeah anyway guys
we've been on a marathon long one
recently this is slightly short not even
a short one to be fair slightly shorter
but anyway guys as always
uh love love love gang gang gang see you
on Thursday guys
[Music]